good evening everyone
welcome to the mit museum my name is
brenda moniapan i'm the director of
programs here at the museum
and i'd like to welcome you to tonight's
event a discussion about
the art and science of solar lights
we're thrilled to be able to offer this
program
this evening in collaboration with arts
at mit
we're going to have a series of paired
discussions tonight you'll get to hear
from
artists designers architects
technologists engineers it's a pretty
fantastic
program that we have for you this
evening i hope you'll enjoy it
and without further ado i'm going to
allow lila kinney
head of arts at mit to introduce the
program
so am i on this or this i'm on this
great
so thank you all for coming and i wanted
to say a few words
about the first section of this this is
a format that we're using tonight that i
think the mit museum has specialized in
those of you who have come to the
cambridge science festival know about
this big ideas for busy people
so forgive our flying through many
interesting issues but i think it's an
interesting way
to make some of the research and
technology and innovation here at mit
sort of accessible in a general and
fairly efficient way
so as brenda mentioned on the heads at
art at arts at mit
and you may or may not know that we
actually have a major arts award here
the eugene mcdermott award in the arts
at mit
which was created by margaret mcdermott
in honor of her husband eugene who is
the founder of texas instruments
and they've been longtime benefactors
and supporters of mit
it really reflects her vision and the
vision of the 13th president of mit
that it's very important to integrate
the arts
into an institution primarily known
for science and engineering and perhaps
one of the reasons that
many of you were here this evening could
i just get a sense has anybody heard of
the mcdermott award
before oh great good thank you and i
think our
2014 recipient oliver eliason who is
here
has recently become familiar with it a
very important
a very important part of the award is
the residency
because we want an artist to sort of
engage with the mit
community in a way that is we hope
mutually
enlightening and beneficial so
oliver's practice and may i ask another
question how many of you were able to
attend the public lecture last night in
10
250. oh good excellent well for those of
you weren't there i'll just say a few
words about his work not to take too
long on the introductions
oliver's practice is very wide-ranging
and we could have
focused the residency on any any number
of things he's well known
for his large-scale installations
for for temporary pavilions
architecture experiments with
sensory processions space light i think
it's a shame
that artists become known only for a few
works that are uh mentioned over and
over again but it's really
i think impossible in his case not to
mention a couple
and one is a project from about a decade
ago called the weather project of the
tate
modern have people heard of that by any
chance
some people nodding well the tate modern
as you may know is a huge
turbine factory that's been converted
into a contemporary art museum
and oliver installed a project there
that
i think took everyone and maybe even him
by surprise
because of the intense public engagement
with it
he um created an artificial sun
at the end of this turbine hall
a mirrored ceiling and put some fog or
mist
into it and the environment sort of
transformed people's experience of that
space
and of one another over two million
people
ended up attending the project and it
really became a kind of marker for a
kind of participatory
art that made one more aware of one's
experience
in his space which is a really
important aspect of his work i think
he'll talk a little bit perhaps tonight
about how
we get from big sun to little sun which
became
the focus of the residency here at mit
you can see in the window beyond if you
didn't notice it
when you came in this portable
solar-powered
handheld lamp called little sun that
oliver calls work of art that works in
life i'll let him
explain more about that but we decided
to use
that as a means for engaging here with
the mit community
over the course of this academic year we
started off by having
the solar the little sun be a challenge
in
a hacking arts event that occurred in
the fall which put
artists entrepreneurs and engineers
together
it was a particular challenge and one of
the members of his studio came over
who's the ceo
little son and architect himself came
over to
judge that competition to mentor the
students
then energy night as you may all know is
a big event annually at the mit museum
it's probably one of the most well
attended events and certainly the most
populous club of for mit
students they organize a showcase of
new energy products each fall and so
in october we installed this exhibition
here and frederick otterson
the engineer who is the co-founder with
olafur
a little son came over for that event
and then this week
we have sort of culminated this series
of interactions around little sun
with a series of meetings with people
like d lab and this is how we got
herald engaged and um
the j-pal group we're economists to
evaluate the
the effectiveness of various
technologies um
for uh emerging economies through fairly
rigorous uh
policy and um uh technical
evaluations and studies controlled
trials we've also engaged of course with
many other aspects of the mit community
the civic media
group a group that's exploring open and
participatory
documentary to think about how we might
bring together
users distributors and
creators if you will of little sun and
of course the programs in art culture
and technology
and architecture so in a way this is a
culmination
of that extended period of an engagement
with the mit community and i'm very
grateful to brenda
and andrew and their team for
allowing us to sort of merge this with
an opportunity to showcase
some of the innovation and new
technologies around
solar power in particular here at mit
so a brief a couple of words about
herald and then i'll hand it over
to herald and then oliver harold quintus
baz was
well there's a very interesting little
story behind this i when i was running
around mit trying to
sort of describe this project the
possibilities for this residency to
people
i happen to be on the mit museum
advisory committee so
one of the places that i presented this
project
was at the advisory committee and
harald's partner and co-founder of
cooper perkins which is a
product uh development company based
here in lexington
gerhard said i know exactly the person
you need to talk to
harald is not only himself
a graduate of mit and also of stanford
we got him first they got him second
but had worked with the d lab here
how many of you are familiar with the d
lab and its work
great it's a wonderful program here at
mit that's
um it's called dialogue design and
dissemination for the
developing world but d lab for short and
it works on
creating sort of effective and
appropriate technologies
for primarily is it primarily
sub-saharan africa or other countries as
well
harald will say a little bit more about
that they have a wonderful international
design
summit in africa and herald is not only
an
instructor in d lab and the chief
technical officer
of cooper perkins but has been really
active in that
international design summit he also
before
going to mit and then to stanford for
his graduate work was
at ideo so he has i think some very
interesting insights to share with us
about design
thinking as a result and cooper perkins
itself
does all kinds of product development
technologies everything from i think he
told me
chilling technology for milk in india to
increase increasing the efficiency of
more drilling equipment
i'm sure he'll give you other examples
so without further ado let me introduce
herald who will talk about his solar
light project and the focus i might say
of this discussion this segment
is going to be on design approaches to
design
for solar lighting and the others will
have different photos
all right um just a quick question
this the clicker for that
ah no problem all right so thank you
leela for the great introduction um
said quite a bit so yes i'm an
instructor d-lab which is two floors up
from here
right up there and
not so long ago in 2007
i was uh in the fourth floor building
three which is that way
meeting with amy smith and ben linder
and patricia and laura stupid and others
and we were struggling with
the problem of a teaching tool for idds
and we were thinking of this particular
problem which was
lighting we knew we wanted to target the
developing world
and and we wanted to think about
addressing this particular problem which
is lighting
uh in the developing world which is
important because people
people in the developing world are often
lighting with kerosene and
not only is it expensive but it's uh it
can also be toxic to handle the fumes
etc
so there was a big opportunity for us to
be able to
fuse solar lighting in a device that
would help us teach particular skills
for idds
and the particular skills we were
looking to teach
were primarily how to use the lathe
we wanted we wanted to take advantage of
the lathe it's a wonderful piece of
equipment
it does many operations uh
hinges all kinds of things fit together
so beautifully with a lathe
uh and it's great to it's it's a great
thing to to use
but before i go on with the leg let me
talk a little bit about uh
idds because i'm you're probably
wondering what it might be all about
so idds is a program focused on teaching
design
creating a network of innovators in the
developing world so
instead of teaching students at
universities we're out there teaching
design
to the the participants of the
developing world and they're from all
over the place
so the idea is to take a group like this
doctors bike mechanics
pastors
across a broad range of countries uh
pakistan india
many countries in africa south america
just everywhere
and and teach these people how to
design and become innovative to develop
technologies that are appropriate to
them
and primarily we do that with exercises
in this case it was a
launch launch a seed down
the four thrawlers down in a building to
hit a particular target
and this was over in ghana kumasi
we are also using charcoal amy smith
is particularly adept at teaching uh
the methods of making charcoal both the
the uh
the creation of the carbon itself and
then the manufacturer of the
briquettes so we do that as well and we
take these people and we teach them the
design process
so they end up being able to do things
like this
follow a follow a design process that
looks familiar to those that studied
engineering
so that they can then develop products
that look like those uh
those are like cassava cassava peelers
and these are treadle pumps
so that they can design these
technologies that they need for
themselves
back to the lathe so the lathe
comes in because we wanted to see if we
could mix the lathe
and solar lighting in some way so we did
the prerequisite
uh sketches uh many many sketches and
thinking breadboards of like how might
this
how might this come together what forms
might it take uh it all
of course had to work with the lathe and
we came up with
this which is uh right here
it's a solar solar light
and the idea here was that people could
machine the outside shell they could
sand the line on this
uh plexiglass disc so they they would
draw a circle and then use
use a sander to send to the line they
would use a hacksaw and a form to bend
the handle
they learned about soldering both the
leds and the wires
rechargeable batteries all that stuff
was
was part of this particular design and
what ended up happening was of course
that
uh people like habib uh now
uh he's i think in india um
was shown here using the form he's
bending he's making the wire frame
around the form there is uh
other participants i think that's mensa
kuma
on the lathe
and the drill press over here to make
these holes as well so they we got
everybody involved in
machining process as well as soldering
learning how to solder which was the
technology we wanted to introduce
because we knew that it was important
for people in the developing world to
become aware
of soldering as a method of generating
uh innovative ideas um using circuits
and electronics
and so then the uh so then we of course
uh used this tool to teach design
and then went on to in our four-week
event to
present our design challenges and have
the participants use
the skills they learn in making this to
be able to
design tackle challenges with water
energy
sanitation and many other fields so
that's uh so that's what this light's
about and
just to give you an idea uh when uh
when we when we got to the participants
on this this
this by the way happened all in one day
because this is just a
method of teaching the participants how
to use particular tools
it was just the beginning of the session
we gave them a bag with a circuit board
some wires leds some plastic plates and
a tube of aluminum
and i don't have the handle wire but we
also gave them that and
from this in about two three hour
sessions three and a half hour sessions
they made this
so anyway that's the solar light thanks
for your attention
so thank you
i started some two years ago now
in collaboration with an engineer to
think about how to
bring solar energy into a project which
did several things
besides the main thing is obviously
delivering light
in areas where there is no access to
energy
to trump jump straight into that what
was very important to us was
the language with with which we could
achieve this
i had worked as an artist for 20 years
and the engineer has actually worked
with solar airplanes and
him and his team was the first people in
91 to fly across america
so he knew a lot about inner solar
airplane in a single seated solar
airplane
so so he knew a lot and
what we looked at was that there was
already a number of
products or projects on
on sort of outside out in the world some
of which are really
quite quite amazing projects but in
general
what we were interested in was to tell a
positive story or try to tell a story
that was not
only aimed at the areas in the world in
which one could not have electricity but
really a kind of a global story
about sharing the responsibility about
having access to energy
so we worked a lot on the design and let
me just briefly show you that
you've seen it maybe over here this is
how it looks
it has a solar panel obviously on the
back and
it has a led and rechargeable batteries
on the inside
and then it has this plastic casing a uv
pro
a uv resistant plastic the point here is
we had a benchmark which was a
production price which is about
five dollars the production price had to
be low in order to
create something that would be sellable
locally in areas
where people are normally spending money
for chaos scenes so
we were competing with oil industry so
to speak this means
five dollars is already quite expensive
and obviously we would very much like
this to be even cheaper
but with a maximum of five dollars we
went through a whole series of design
processes
which led us to to to this
still the ambition was to make something
which is beautiful something that feels
good something that a child who is our
typical user a child between 6
and 16 or a young adult if you want
and something that would be easy to
carry around with you
the sort of beginning started with
how does energy actually feels and the
great
challenge we saw when talking to people
in this case we would study a little bit
south of
upper uh close to avasa we're starting
the kind of abstract of the confidence
you know how to tell a story
and it was it turned out it was much
easier to tell a story
to be it was much easier if we were
emotional rather than being functional
so instead of talking about the
practicalities for
four hours of sun and one evening of
light and so on it became clear that
if people liked it it was much more
easier to convince them to take it so
this means the emotional component
was a much stronger driver than let's
say the functional component
and that inspired the design this means
that it had to be something
if it was laying around and a child saw
it they would immediately go and take it
we got some advice from some engineers
from different people
and their advice very often you know was
it was robust but occasionally
misleading such as
an advice with saying just make sure it
works
no make it high quality focus on the
functionality and don't worry
about the design this is africa it was
like it's much more important that it
works
what do they care about design a typical
kind of
ngo type of standard answer
and and obviously we very quickly
realized this was not only wrong it was
also condescending and very
typical for the type of language that is
somehow um
in this area in which we're working
where a certain part of the world being
resourceful
is addressing a certain other part of
the world which is the endless resource
weak or resource less and and so the the
kind of the idea of the design the
language the campaign the project
very much also became about building a
language which was not
stigmatizing a language which addressed
something that we shared instead of
polarizing it into
what do we not share and say we have you
don't have
so we all always talk about what desires
do we have in common
well it's very busy we want to be happy
we want to have something in our lives
that we like
something we treasure we want to care
about each other and so on and so forth
and out of that
the dinners on projects so to sort of
grew its language
should i be flipping a few images
yeah maybe play the video so we have
done a number of kind of campaign
related projects
i'll talk a little bit about the
business model but
but let me just show you one sort of
typical campaign and see this
this idea of the aspiration to be um how
should you say
to be positive or to to address
something
does it play with sound
anyway so this is in denmark the royal
theater
it's just i think it's a minute long so
just have a look at it
um
now
so the um so as you can tell the idea is
to suggest a degree of interdependence
share and share the experience this idea
of experience something together being a
collective experience the feeling that i
went into this theater was before
show on a different or not related
matter so i went in at the start
i told everybody okay now i do like this
that we filmed it and then during the
show we then edit it quickly together
so that at the end of the show i came
out again and showed it to the audience
and then we sent it to all of the
audience and asked them to pass it on
right so so it became a kind of an
online project and
the theater event was just to get some
sort of stuff that we could use in
social media
and this is a little bit how we try to
work with the campaigning to address
you know the the idea of having
resources being resourceful doing
something together
communicating something which is not
necessarily focusing on the
functionality of it
and so on and so forth having said that
the principle in this as you can see you
can buy it over here
in the shop is that we sell it i believe
here it's around say what is 28
or something and we are pushing it into
as many shops as we can and obviously
this is
turning out to be quite a bit of work
but we're selling it here at higher
price builder
we're then delivering it gradually into
sales outlets of various sorts private
sector ngo sector governmental systems
in in momentarily we are only working in
rural africa
in eight countries so the profit from
selling it here goes into delivering the
light but it is also based on a
market-driven model
uh locally meaning that the profit
generated locally then stays and
hopefully pays for ordering a new
lamp and this of course turns out to be
incredibly complex but still it's
working
relatively um relatively well and we are
you know
currently we are i believe we are 12
people working
a few uh in africa and and a handful of
people doing the office
in berlin and it's somehow we are sort
of breaking even
right now so so we are quite happy we
made 250
000 lamps out of out of which
approximately 200 have been delivered
one-third of those have been delivered
off-grid and looking at the sort of
curves the off-grid
is increasing is much on a much steeper
curve than the
sort of the on-grid and we only just
started selling them in america
online and next week the moma store
of course mit museum store comes first
and then the moma store in new york
comes uh comes second but it's a big
deal because then they send out their
catalog and it's on the kind of cover
and the back of the moment
store catcher the spring catalog i think
they call it an online and all of that
so slowly
we're getting it out we're just about to
also
uh make a phone charger we're going into
communication we're trying to
you know essentially it's just all about
money getting money so collecting money
to get
like a slightly bigger lamp going like a
system lamp going with two plugs and a
lamp and a
ceiling system and so on but this is
further down the line
so i told you a little bit about the
business model about our
campaigning idea the idea of awareness
building and policy making and
you know addressing the food in the door
with solar energy and then this role of
the design so that was like
little sun in a nutshell i hope thank
you
so now i think you came up here these
are a little high
these stools feel like i'm at the
kitchen counter or something
so i think that one of the most
interesting things about this pairing
is that you're both very interested in
empowering people but you're coming at
it with very
from very different directions the deep
i guess we would call it the diy
model and then this sort of larger sense
of
the significance of having access to
energy feeling like you have what heard
you say a power station in your hand
so i'm wondering if we could expand a
little bit and contrast
and also have you react to the others
model of approaching that issue of
empowering people
all right uh yeah i would i would say
instead of maybe
diy maybe iiy okay
innovate it yourself uh because i think
uh what we're trying to do is we're
trying to
uh make sure that people receive a bit
of inspiration
and education in order to be able to
develop technologies that are
appropriate for their situations and
that's
that's the way we approach it and we're
across many
many different fields geographically
and many different kinds of problems as
i alluded to before so that's uh
so the this particular solar light again
was just a tool
for us to inspire people and it worked
uh
fabulously well we had uh uh several
people really wanting to
to take off with a light and i had to
convince them not to start
focusing on selling that because it's
really expensive i said no no
take this inspiration and re-channel it
maybe design your own light
or do something else but don't don't
make copies of this one
it's a teaching tool and do you have
actually information on follow-up or
what people did with their
you know soldering and circuit making
experience
so uh so the one individual that i know
is uh mets akuma he's uh
he's selling lights over in in ghana
and there are other people that have
done many different things
not everybody then follows through with
uh light making because it's not
the idds wasn't about making lights
again the lights was our tool so some
people
some people were working on different
technologies of uh generating power from
water
or other medical challenges trying to
solve
aids transmission from breast milk uh
and those kinds of areas and yes some of
those people have continued
there are when i was putting the
presentation together i was looking at
the
at the images that have taken a long
time along the way of idds and i was
recognizing the people it's like oh
and they're doing a water filter and
they're doing the birthing kit and
they're
and so there's a whole bunch of
innovators out there already so
it's working but uh i don't have the
numbers in my head on
who has done exactly what so oliver what
do you think about this idea of
giving people the tools as opposed to
giving them a sort of emotional
empowerment
and a sense of connectivity i think
which is also important
yeah i think i think the challenge is to
do it
in a way where you don't come across as
the teacher who's
giving i think
i mean this of course is a little bit
complex i think the
the what i have learned from traveling
around in east africa has been very much
that
i'm always much easier with regards to
being integrated into a dialogue or
working together on something
when i come to take instead of when i
come to give
this means if i'm there to suggest
that i know something they don't and
then i go oh so let me then teach you
it's it's it's just a little complex and
obviously it's
i mean coming from a university like mit
mit is sort of difficult to go and say
so the way we work we we really go and
we
base it we base the the principles on
that we are coming and we think
there is an opportunity for which we can
learn something we can take something
and we almost
i wouldn't say we we you know
it has worked better the moments where
we and we were very clear to say we are
not here to teach you anything you're
great already
very creative we are coming to take and
and and this is why we're asking people
to make their own businesses
develop their own systems and so on
sometimes i mean it's hard to generalize
about it but
it's also because i work as a teacher at
the adizabar university
and i've been very interested in the
kind of you know the
the need to be a little bit sensitive to
the colonizing language that one without
even think about it brings about into
these sort of teacher
teacher student situations um
and this this is why i think the
campaigning and the language around
lindsay
we we have almost now stopped also when
working in africa to talk about
off-grid versus on-grid or this idea
instead we talk we talk about the right
to power the right to life
right to light is like having a right to
life and in that sense it's something
which is both off and on great
i mean clearly then you know having an
education is different than having a no
education somebody has to teach so it's
a little more complex i can see that
but i just think
i think the degree of sensitivity is
needed when moving into areas
without being no clumsy
so it strikes me that one of the huge
issues here is just
the size of this problem you often use
the 1.6 billion people
who don't have access to electricity
creating
innovators one at a time it's hard to
scale these things up
so i'm just wondering if you could speak
a little bit to that
challenge of scaling up these solutions
how does your approach or d labs
approach
deal with that yeah so that's actually a
a very tough challenge because of the
scale also because as we were talking
before there isn't
there isn't a copy and paste answer to
these problems so you can't
you can't develop a solution guatemala
and expect to run over to
a sub-saharan africa and have it take
off uh you need to you need to be quite
knowledgeable about the space where
you're going into
so yeah at d lab we're particularly
focused one of the classes i'm teaching
is design for scale which is an effort
to
continue that educational process for
the students at mit
on how to design their technologies for
higher volume manufacturers so they can
be impactful we also
broaden uh in the students the point of
view of what
impact uh is so that it's not it's not
uh
head counting or dollar counting but it
can be broader in terms of who benefits
and how they benefit
so they could so you can think about
scaling in different ways so
yes it is a challenge and we spend time
uh instructing students
on on how to do it in the developing
world it's different because the
resources and the education everything
else is slightly different so uh
there's uh there's more of an organic
growth model happening
uh in the developing world and we've
seen that too so yes
it's hard and we do focus on it so
i think in your case oliver the scaling
up is also a question of distribution
and that is a huge part of the challenge
right
beyond the again beyond the functional
the distribution
yes and it's the question of um you know
we chose then to be
primarily market driven even though a
lot of the market driven projects we're
working on are in fact
ngo projects as a lot of ngos are
leaning towards using market systems for
let's say resource optimization um
the scalability i think
there was i think what's this story you
know the
story about the condom condoms and hiv
they were trying to push out condoms
and it was really difficult and they
went into the rural areas and every time
they brought the condoms
somebody got there before them and that
was coca-cola
or you know cigarettes or soft you know
sort of makeup and stuff
how come the makeup got there before the
condoms
and obviously it has to do with this
idea of push and pull and people who
know about market economy which i don't
would know you know how to facilitate
the push versus the pool
so pool is like the the desires
pulling the coca-cola from the company
all the way out into the
you know into the areas where there is
not even a road but there's plenty of
coca-cola
and and uh and and so the idea is that
the desire
locally seems to be an incredibly strong
force and this is why then they change
the campaigning for condoms
from being about you know addressing a
problem yeah the
problem of you know getting sick and hiv
and so on to to campaigning for
well almost campaigning for promiscuity
you know kind of having fun and more sex
and then the campaign the kind of a
condom campaign became more successful
like let's have more sex it's great and
and in that sense
we have learned a lot i think to to if
we want to go down the market driven
principles because one could also
say well you know maybe thinking about
every fifth person
in this room would not have access to
energy is just like all the people over
there
and these so you have energy you don't
have energy what about just say okay
let's just quit it because let's see
isn't it
isn't it so that the war in afghanistan
is like a billion dollar a week
or whatever billion dollar every two
weeks or something like this incredible
so it's two billion dollars then
everybody all these people have one of
these
so maybe we should instead of going it's
going to take a long time as you say
delivering all the lamps through the
market economy and we know market iconic
b
can be pretty dodgy also right it's an
explorative poker
because so anyway so so maybe there are
other ways
but for the time being we don't have any
other ways and it does work it does seem
to
there is something in it when we have a
young group of
30 uh boys who are a former alumni
program by plan in zimbabwe in a
in a city which i don't remember now
and they they it's a door-to-door sales
system
these 30 boys they are up to me they are
making
on an average between 40 and 60 a week
each selling this so this is by far the
most the most successful business
opportunity
they've been in and the funny thing is
the the kind of
importer the wholesaler sort of the
personal input he makes
a ton of money and we go okay i can't
just share a little bit but no no
we realized we we can't start telling
them how to
you know what to do and how to do the
business better it's very aggressive so
the market
system proves efficient but also a
little bit unfair
because and so on and so forth but but
this seems
this has facilitated a growing model now
now there's
six other groups each with 30 uh um
boys between 20 20 and 25 i think now
they are testing and taking down they
need a little loan we've
received the first laps half the
production price they said half the
money
a little bit of money and and and the
road is still bumpy but we are
finding successful models and
unfortunately we cannot take that model
from zimbabwe and apply it on another
country we have to in a different
country
totally different different government
different system different tax system
and you could you would think that you
could take zimbabwe and take them and
put it into zambia
but you can't er we haven't been able to
so far
at least so yes the scalability
this group over there is a really big
it's like a close to impossible
challenge within a short
period it would be easier to like drop
them off with an airplane
which of course would have a lot of
other problems but basically
coming to shut down the wall one week
before
and present and so on so i want to open
the floor up very soon to you but i have
one final question i think we would be
remiss with the focus of this
pairing without talking a little bit
about design and i know that
um i was about approaches you know
contrasting approaches to design
and i know harald and i were just
talking because he has this background
at stanford
where he got his master's degree in
mechanical engineering
he also was at ido before i happened
just a little anecdote to take three mit
students three art scholars out to
stanford we had a big national hackathon
in the d
school there the mit students were so
struck by how different the approach was
in herald we have the mit versus the
ido approach and the stanford approach
was this kind of different so i was
yeah it's a little mixed right and then
oliver as an artist
has thought so much about how to
activate participation
in his works and i know the experience
of individuality and collectivity at the
same time
is something that his work in particular
i think is really
masterful at creating so i just want to
see if i can
get you both to address this approach
approach to design
yeah regardless maybe even of the the
product but maybe how it's also affected
how you've
um created these solar products yeah
so um the it is true that
uh when i went to mit and stanford the
approaches to teaching the
engineering and designer different and i
can appreciate that so now
at cooper perkins i'm encouraging our
group to think
creatively by teaching them skills
drawing skills
on the right hand side of the brain and
that
that is helping to think more laterally
rather than linearly
education especially at mit and other
universities like that tends to be a
linear process
so you can be channeled into a
particular linear approach and the
broader thinking the brainstorming all
that process
i think is what generates the richness
of ideas uh in combination with getting
a different a different group of people
not
not 20 people all the same but 20 people
all different
participating in a brainstorming process
and selecting ideas
i think is what what makes the design
process in that
in that style much more powerful we use
that at
idds it's an important ingredient we
always we always
when we're selecting participants try to
select participants from different parts
of the world but also different
occupations
so we can put pastors together with
mechanics and get different solutions to
problems
so that that kind of lateral thinking
approach was uh very heavily taught at
stanford
a little bit of design over there as
well product design
um and it as i showed in the images in
the presentation it was part of the
process for designing the
the lamp where we brainstorm and we came
up with configurations of the light and
we
we made little models of how it might
work and then uh
and then decided on the on the final
form that you see
and we actually uh we actually show that
process to the participants so they can
run that process themselves
great thanks perfect
yeah i think um
for me the design is
how should i say applying how onto why
so if i have sorted out what i want to
do as an idea
i need to sort of start applying sort of
language onto the idea so the idea
takes shape or gets a body but also
takes space and designers obviously more
than just
you know wrapping it with some material
and deciding but essentially is
if the idea contains this idea that it
has to touch
somebody like in one way or the other
the design would need to
amplify that in a body so the design
you know is i believe like almost like
an amplifier of the intentionality of
the idea
but having said that the design
obviously is also more complex because
it's a part of an economy it's a part of
you know the environment
it's a part of a lot of other structures
which is outside the labor involved with
assembling this
is that labor you know done at the
source or can it be applied later on in
the design process you know could one
send the components and then make a
factory then
at the assembly is the design is also
the economy of the production
both the economy like financially but
also the economy of labor and time and
how people are
you know how people devise this
so um so i so i think of design often
like
um you know the the quality of the
language
and the design's purpose is to make sure
that what was said
at the beginning actually comes out at
the end
so the design doesn't sort of de-root
the y
on the sort of half halfway through
and this is i i say this because i think
this also applies on
how i work when i work as an artist
and as an artist i'm obviously
occasionally celebrating the idea of
doing
no good or doing nonsense
or unpredictable successes such as
improvising and just so i so i just want
to keep it a little bit open the why
doesn't have to be a very sort of
pointed why it can also be okay let's
just
not do something reasonably
reasonable today but let's just come and
sometimes there's a lovely work of art
right in there as well
if you don't mind me adding that detail
no i'm glad you did
so we want to take some questions from
you now
please are you trying to see
the production of these in the places
where they will be used
did you hear that so whether i am trying
to put the production into the places
where they use
yes we were very much like to to
produce them i mean right now the solar
panel is
from california the leds german the
plastic is also german
the inside is from taiwan the batteries
are chinese
and so on and so forth but essentially
the first
step which we have been looking into
would be to do an assembly
factory or a sort of assembly place so
we can sort of ship the components
and this uh for the for our next scale
they would
take 15 people on a sort of
assembly type sorry one space factory
very basic
uh the pro the challenge here is that um
it's not actually the salary in the
economy and so on it would probably make
it even a little bit cheaper which is
this
the upside the downside is that shipping
a
green environmentally friendly certified
product
very often has some tax benefits in it
this means we can send this
into nigeria for since for instance tax
free because it goes
in as a sort of green world bank
certified green lighting africa program
and so on and so forth
if we send it as electronic components
we have to pay 45
tax on some of it 25 on some other 10 or
more and this means that
that actually takes the upside down away
it's very possibly how they sort of
environmentally
industry being the good industry is also
you know having
a but you know once you hit a certain
scale that then change turns over again
and
and so it's just a question of of time
before it
then pays off again
there's a microphone here is do we have
other questions there's one on the other
side as well
one more yeah
i haven't had a chance to look at this
very closely but
um
um
yeah this is a it's it sort of looks
complex but it's actually a
it's it's a two-part injection mold
system so there's a lid
and a base and the and and
then of course i made i made some effort
into make it
like very wearable because it's it does
represent a certain value so it's not
something you're likely during the
charging
in the day you're not likely to put it
out if it represents what you would
spend
in two months on kerosene for lightning
for a family
you would you you you don't see very
often that you sort of lay it in the
garden and then go to work and come back
and
so so so that was one of the sort of
user um
modes the thing is that it actually has
a ventilated system inside so a little
so on so some work went into making sure
that when it's in the sun
uh it heats up immensely especially the
black part here
and this means it has to take it has an
air intake you can kind of see
in an air outtake and the flow go sort
of wraps around the batteries and goes
out again we engineered that quite a
while to keep the battery from
overheating because they don't
like now the batteries are not the worst
batteries
you can get but these are not the best
batteries also because they had to be in
a reasonable price range
so um
no but i mean we don't get that we we
don't really get up in the area where
the led is just because the batteries
have
they have 900 or or about 900 recharges
to full
and we would want to you know heating up
900 times
it's also quite a challenge for the lamb
so we worked a lot on
sort of little cooling uh sort of from
arabic architecture cooling principle
that the the
rise of hot air draws in cooler air and
so on
it only took three percent of the we re
we took it we did it it only took the
pro
heat down three percent but just enough
for kind of um
at the top of the heat that's quite a
bit and that's
that's crazy but typically when charging
yes i mean
i we encourage on the on the
if we have any input we it very often
actually charges
sort of standing or leaning and this
means that there is a bigger
likelihood that that it actually has an
uptake this is
this is also not so bad it should also
hit like this
i would add that the uh that the
biggest price uh costly parts of the
light are
the internals the batteries the solar
cell
the led and the circuit board and the
plastics are
are a smaller part so you can focus your
design effort
on on getting the features making that
making that product of high quality
and it's not uh it's not that big a
penalty relative to everything else so
you wouldn't
you wouldn't uh take this and cut off
all of its wings
and come out with a significantly
cheaper product it's a good design
i think we're done so on to the next
panel thank you very much
thank you
so
okay good evening everybody we are going
to start the second discussion now
and now we are going to take a step back
i think because apart from design
challenges and delivery challenges
uh there are other challenges behind
this technology which is the technology
itself
so you have to design them first and
there is a lot of science behind that
so in the next 40 minutes or so you'll
probably learn
more about the science of solar cells
than you ever wanted to know but we'll
try to make it interesting
and when i tried to describe this
little sound project to my daughter who
is only five
her first reaction was yeah i know what
you're talking about
it's like fraud is fearl first they
laughed
and then i started thinking a little bit
more about it and they thought
it's a perfect test system to actually
look at different
aspects of any technology now this
technology is magic we don't really know
what kind of innovation went into it
but there are aspects to it which can be
applicable to
any kind of technology i just look at
them so
first one is functionality obviously you
want your device to work
as intended like in this particular case
it's supposed to give you light
when you need it another aspect is
stability
so you wanted to work in the cave
outside when it's lenient when it's not
leaning and when it's cold or hot
so that's stability of operation
portability is
obviously it's nice if you can put it in
your pocket and take it with you where
you need it
efficiency it's how much energy you can
get out of your device
and how much uh useless energy you get
like in this particular case you get
light which is what
fraud needs and it doesn't seem that
this device gets really hot
because that would be unwanted energy
which would drive efficiency down
and also it doesn't have to be beautiful
but it doesn't hurt if it's beautiful
right
it's always nice to use something that
looks nice
so now let's look at our technology
which is photovoltaics
so the first aspect is functionality
so it's supposed to work so what does it
do it converts
solar energy into electricity which in
turn can be used to create light
or to make work our electronic devices
which we love so much and depends so
much upon
so this functionality is based on some
science
so how does it work that's where it gets
scientific but don't turn away please
so although we usually talk about light
as waves
actually when a light interacts with
matter in this case at solar cell
it reveals its quantum nature and what
it means it actually consists of a lot
of little particles called photons
and when those particles interact with
the material of the solar cell
they start free another type of particle
which is electron
so it was sitting quietly in its
energetically preferred place in the
solar cell
but now it it breaks free and it can
move
and it leaves a hole behind and then if
we can make
those particles move we can collect them
into the electrical circuit
and they will make work and work is
needed to
make this device work okay
so that's how it works it obviously
works when the sun is
up and there is a lot of light say in
the summer on a
nice cloudless day but we also would
like this to work when the
sun is going down because you still need
your cell phone then right
and also you would like it to work when
it rains or when it's windy
or in any kind of ambient condition
another aspect is portability it's also
nice if that is a kind of a device
that you can actually put in your pocket
and take it places
where there is no grid and as we've
heard in the previous uh conversation
and that's obvious that portability goes
hand in hand with aesthetics because if
you have a huge power plant somewhere in
there there's probably people don't
really care how it looks like nobody is
going to see it
but if it's something you want people to
actually take with them
around you better make it look nice so
that's
important and then
we go to partability also goes with
efficiency
because the requirements to efficiency
are now more strict
because if it's small you also want it
to be light
if it's light it means you cannot use
too much material
so that's a challenge but still you want
to squeeze as much
energy out of it as possible so its
requirements to efficiency become even
strict if you are trying to make
something portable
okay so what are the problems with
efficiency it seems there is so much
sunlight if you just
collect it and convert into electrical
current it shouldn't be a problem
well the problem is not only light is
made out of particles
it's actually made of different kinds of
particles
as you know after in when there is a
rainbow there are different colors in
light
and those different colors are actually
different types of particles
those photons and what is different is
they carry different amount of energy
but there is only certain amount of
energy quantum of energy
which is needed to set free an electron
and every photon can only set free one
electron
and so then if you just look at how much
energy different
photons of different colors carry you
see that some of them actually don't
have enough
so they are totally useless they cannot
do work for us
some of them have too much so they do
the work but they have excess of energy
we just ends up heating our solar cell
and it's again it's lost
so the efficiency is going down
so that's a challenge so what are you
going to do
with this so it calls for some material
innovations so what kind of innovations
you can think of
so the obvious one is you want to change
your solar cell
so if you can come up with solar cell
made of some kind of material or
different materials or an artificial
metamaterial
that actually makes use of all the
energy of all the photons very
efficiently
that would be one solution and then
another solution which may sound
cajun but you can actually change the
sun
because this sun we have that's the only
one we have right
we don't have a choice but it generates
all those photons of different
energies which seem not to work nicely
with our technology which is a pv
cell so we don't like that so what can
we do about it
how can we change sun well we just need
to remember that
heat is actually light and light is heat
so we saw that those unwanted photons
they generate a lot of heat which was a
problem
but we can actually turn it to our
advantage because if you think of it
our sun is just a giant ball of burning
gas which is just heat and it generates
all those photons of different energy so
what if we just
absorb them into little sun we just make
a tiny artificial sun
which just absorbs the whole energy of
all those photons and heats up but then
we design the sun
in such a way that it only emits
good kind of photons just the right size
which can be used by our solar cell very
efficiently
then obviously we have another material
challenge because this sun
it has to be made of some kind of
material which only meets those photons
and those materials have to be stable at
high temperatures because
it's going to be hot so there are a lot
of different challenges in the design
of solar cells and the next two speakers
evan and jeffrey are going to
tell you about different aspects of this
technology and
challenges they're facing and what kind
of innovations they come up with to
overcome those challenges
so i give it to them
thanks fetta for the great introduction
and i think it makes both jeff and my
lives easier
so today what i'd like to share with you
is a technology that we've been working
on
and it's collaborative so of course i
wanted to acknowledge the people that
actually really do it
um my students andre leonard and david
biermann and my former postdoc young
young as well as our collaborators who
also a student walker chan
who works with yvonne celenovich as well
as martin solicek in physics
and what we've been working on is
thinking about these kind of
solar thermal photovoltaic devices and
i'll talk a little bit about how this
works
but i think hopefully from sveta's intro
you'll see it we're harnessing
the sun in the form of heat to
eventually generate electricity
so when you typically think about the
sun in the form of heat how you harness
that
you think of solar thermal approaches
such as
this power this kind of steam power
plant designs
what you may be familiar with and you've
seen around are these kind of
these parabolic trough type
configurations where you
concentrate the sun again like in the
form of heat to heat up
this working fluid in this tube it's
usually of oil
and this oil then drives the steam cycle
right so and then the advantage of this
approach is svet already said is you can
now
collect all of the different wavelengths
from the sun and
use it as heat right to drive your steam
engine and generate electricity
but typically these are much more
efficient at the utility scale
and there are challenges with
maintenance costs right in terms of
these large-scale systems
but there could be an added advantage
because one of the challenges
is that you also want to you don't have
sun all the time
and you might want to store some of this
via a thermal method such as a thermal
storage
mechanism such that you can have
continuous electricity generation right
power generation
so as fed already said the other
approaches is using these photovoltaics
however only certain wavelengths are
useful to excite these charge carriers
to generate electricity right but the
advantage of this approach is it's
extremely scalable
right for your rooftop or to larger
scale systems
and there's solid state right there's no
moving parts at all
and the challenge however like i said
already is that
it's very hard to store energy right
electrical energy
so when you look at these two different
approaches you'd like
you'd like to think that maybe we could
combine them in some way
such that you could take advantage of
the great things about these
technologies
so if we can try to harness the full
spectrum the sun
in the form of heat and we can make it
scalable and solid state and also offer
this continuous opportunity
to generate power this would be great
and the opportunity
is using what we call solar thermal
photovoltaics
and so the idea is you take a typical
configuration of a photovoltaic
cell where you you collect all the you
have the sun shining on this
photovoltaic cell
and instead of this in fact you have
an intermediate convergent process where
we have this uh
this uh materials of a selective
absorber emitter so what we're doing
here
is that again we're collecting now the
the whole spectrum of the sun
and that form the heat by absorbing it
with this absorber
and then we're transferring this heat to
a high enough temperature
such that we can target that target the
ideal wavelength
right that the pv cell is actually using
these photons
and using this kind of design of this
emitter
such that then we can get efficient
power generation
and so you would think well well zachary
how do you go about doing this and the
reason why we're thinking about this
approach is that in fact theoretically
you can get very very high efficiencies
over about 80 or so so the key
is in the materials design and
ultimately it's in the design of this
kind of intermediate converter
this selective absorber emitter and that
of also how you design the pv cell
to match the temperatures that you need
to thermally emit
to what we call the band gap of the pv
cell right
so to give you a little bit of
perspective though because we're looking
at particular wavelengths in fact
this emission the storm emission has to
be at very high temperatures
usually on the order about a thousand
degrees celsius
so how do we do this right so i just
give you a schematic of the technology
that we're really focused on
we're looking at this planar setup just
here so the sun comes in here we can
concentrate the sun so we can get it
hotter and hotter right this absorber
emitter can be at higher and higher
temperatures because that's what we need
and so we we absorb this total spectrum
of the solar radiation
using these carbon nanotubes it turns
out the reason we're using these kind of
carbon nanotube structures they're very
good absorbers
they're almost near the ideal perfect
absorber of the black body absorber
right so you can see that absorptivity
is close to one in this case
so we're really trying to absorb as much
as possible and meanwhile as i said then
you can get it high enough temperature
so that then you can try to tailor the
emission
right close to the bandgap of the pv
cell and in this case we've been working
with our collaborators where they've
been designing these one-dimensional
photonic crystals which consist of these
different layered stacks of silicon and
silicon dioxide
films and that way we can get
constructive interference such that you
can emit
close to this ideal kind of a band gap
of the pv
cell and of course there are tricks to
this right and i just won't go into too
many of the subtleties but in fact
you can see here that we placed the
carbon nanotubes selectively
in this particular area of this total of
the total area the active area
and the reason we do this is in fact you
may recall from
some maybe physics lectures that when
you have very good absorptivity
you also have great emissivity right and
when you have too
high emissivity you lose all the heat
too so we've actually done a geometric
type configuration to help us with this
problem where if we
now change the area ratio between
what's the active area of this emitter
compared to that of the absorber
and we coat the rest of this with a very
low emissivity material
essentially we're kind of changing the
energy balance of the system so we can
really
maximize absorption if we get to higher
and higher kind of levels of
input power from the solar from the
solar light so we have to concentrate it
at higher levels
and this way then we can actually really
improve the efficiency
of the absorption absorption process
while minimizing some of this
emission so these are the kinds of
materials that we're working with
and uh so far we've demonstrated uh
three to four times
higher efficiencies that that has been
reported it's about three to four
percent efficiencies overall which is
relatively low still but what with our
work we've shown that if we just make
these systems slightly bigger
then in fact you can reach 20 percent
conversion efficiencies
which make them comparable to silicon
cells which is the ones that everyone's
talking about now
and there's again the theoretical
potential is much higher
so with that i thought i'd just show you
a video of some of these images that
we've
were taken from our uh
from our media hope in the mit
mechanical engineering department john
frieda
just give you a little perspective of
what the system looks like
when it's operating
sorry i lost my cursor i play this
okay here we go so this is actually
looking front down onto the absorber
this is another example of these carbon
nanotube absorbers and this is your pv
cell we're placing it on top
in this planar system here and
stop playing oops
uh i'm not sure why it stopped
but uh oh thank you
okay so here's the absorber so this is
kind of looking in from the
from the perspective of the sun and here
is an another example
and you can see us placing it close to
the pv cell and here is when we start to
open the shutter to have our simulated
solar spectrum
onto our device
and you can see now that it's glowing
hot which indicates that it's at very
high temperatures
and that's where it's emitting right to
the pv cell
and so it just gives you a little bit of
perspective as to the types of
experiments that we're doing
to help realize and develop materials
that can help us kind of realize
the potential of this technology so
thank you very much
okay how's everybody doing
good okay hi i'm jeff
uh i am here to tell you about a project
that we're working on
that's trying to make solar pv 3d and i
thought i'd start by handing some things
out
and actually i thought you might be
interested in what a solar cell
what the active part of the solar cell
is what's the part that's doing all the
work so i have that here
and in this way you don't have to take
apart and break your little sons
but this is it this is what's inside
of of your of your solar cell this is
what's doing all the work and then
everything else is just
sort of you know encapsulation and you
can see that i just broke it and that's
fine
i want you to break this i'm going to
hand this around breaking things is a
great thing touch it feel it break it
i tell my students you know i tell my
kids and my students you learn best by
picking yourself up right
so break stuff make mistakes i'm passing
this around just so you can feel what
the solar cell actually is like
right that's actually mostly silicon
which is just sand
that we've put a lot of energy into to
make into silicon
right so that's where all the cost is in
terms of the material that's in there
and then here's what the final solar
cell looks like right so i'm going to
hand this out too
this you'll notice this weighs a lot
more because it's encapsulated
which is something you need to do to
give it the 20-year lifetime
that you get if you go to say home depot
now the um
first of all can anybody guess where i
bought that solar panel
that one there best price you get for
those solar panels
any guess ebay you bet you bet if you
want to buy solar panels that you can
break or make into
you know functional panels go to ebay
it's better prices than china
this is actually um actually they come
from china and then
anyway this is what happens in
counseling what do you notice about
these panels though
there's one thing i want you to notice
there's a hint in the title
they're flat right but that's not
optimal right in fact if you just look
around nature does not collect sunlight
in a flat manner the tops of trees are
not flat now that's not necessarily the
best example
because trees are designing and
optimizing around many factors
like survival right water distribution
weight and so forth
but solar cells solar collection you can
pass this around break it do whatever
you want take it home
right seriously um they're they're flat
and they don't need to be and that's not
optimal right
so how do you go three-dimensional what
would happen well that's the question we
asked
and you wouldn't have asked this a
little while ago because the materials
cost dominated over the installation
cost
that's no longer true so now you can ask
questions like what happens if we waste
a little material
but go 3d for example so it turns out
that
it's very easy to compute if you had say
five flat panels like that
laid out flat and you want to compute
how much energy you get from that in a
day
depending on when and where you are in
the world that's easy to compute
but what if you just fold it up right
that's easy what if you just fold them
up and make a cube
right that's actually not easy to
compute and really people haven't
thought about this because again the
materials cost would have killed you
10 years ago won't anymore so the
question is first of all
what is the best 3d shape for a solar
panel if you go 3d
and that was the first question we want
to ask we found all sorts of beautiful
designs right that we thought well what
if we just try some of these
but then we thought let's be a little
smarter about it you know we're
engineers right
so let's engineer this and what we did
is we built actually a really cool
simulation that's based on the
properties of evolution
so it actually uses something called a
genetic algorithm can take any random
assortment any random 3d shape
and you can tell it where you are and
when you are and it'll give you
an emergent order right and it'll tell
you what the optimal structure
for that given location should be right
if you were to go 3d
right how do you maximize the power so
that was
a kind of cool and then we uh we said
well okay that's just a simulation how
about let's build it
and so as uh oliver mentioned we don't
actually
think too much about design at least uh
i don't so i i for we first built this
uh
and we said well that you know this
looks uh like pretty good to us
then we went to our architecture friends
and they said no no no
that doesn't look good at all you need
to do this and then we said well we
can't buy solar panels that look like
this so we sort of compromised and we
had some iterations and we
were now and please you know take these
break them do what you want these are
these are just you know these are just
to touch and feel it
this is 3d pv so we built these we put
them on the rooftop
of our building and we measure data and
here's the sun
going across one of these 3d panels you
can see sometimes you're wasting
panels and here you're absorbing and
then it changes during the day
but one thing that's really interesting
well we put these on the rooftop of our
building to do the testing
and i'll tell you i just moved here from
california and
all the simulations were for sun only
right
because it's easy to do sun only it's
hard to do clouds
and i we just needed one sunny day just
one
um and it was really frustrating because
it took two weeks to get that in boston
and i'm looking at the california
weather on my phone
right every day all sun but actually it
was really cool because what happened is
the bad weather of boston
actually helped us learn something
really cool about going 3d that we had
not predicted which is that it's
actually better in cloudy on cloudy days
because when you go 3d you take
advantage of scattered light
of diffuse light you can't do that when
you're 2d right
so that was really cool actually and i i
think the boston weather
right so anyway we tested it and some
cool things happen right so if you look
at
the the power you can generate versus
height
it's linear with height so if you have a
confined base area
you know you can just keep going up
right that makes sense because now
you're collecting light
when the sun is shining kind of you know
on the side um
and so you go higher up you're going to
collect more light what's also
interesting is the worst time of day is
noon
for the same reason right when the sun
is overhead
you do worse than as the sun kind of
goes down around the edges
but what's cool so this is a flat panel
and this is the power you get during the
day
right that's the typical power curve for
a day and if you
look at that you got about five five and
a half hours of usable electricity
if you if you dual axis track a solar
cell
you can you can get up to eight because
you can go much higher because you're
now tracking the sun
each day but we don't do that because
it's moving parts on your rooftop and
that breaks and it costs a lot of money
so it's not cost effective right with 3d
built into the structure because you've
wasted a little material
built into the structure you have the
eight hours right because now you're
always sort of generating a constant
amount of
of power um no matter where the sun is
and we can actually optimize for that we
didn't even try to optimize that in this
particular case so this is sort of what
we're what we're
we've been excited about and you know we
talked to um
different people about where we could
try to um uh to work with this kind of
thing and one of the first
interesting opportunities that came out
was by the way we still have not been
able to build a panel like this
but we're thinking about it um is is
e-bikes right so there's this
nice uh architecture's rendition of a a
charging station where you have
area can find uh you know you have a
limitation
in your area you don't want to put solar
panels across this beautiful square
but maybe if you put a tower that's been
optimized in the right way
um you could charge say 30-40 bikes a
day now we think e-bikes who
uses e-bikes right well there are 120
million of them in china
right so there are places not the u.s
where e-bikes are using there are some
universities um
like the university of washington where
uh actually they've shown that if you
if you force e-bikes onto students you
get much less traffic problems
right near campus much less parking
problems too so that's one area that
we're looking at we're looking at other
designs and then we thought the last
thing i'll say
and i'll stop is we we thought well what
you know listen these designs are kind
of hard we've made some that actually
are foldable so you ship them flat
you crank them and you can you can get
go 3d but it's still hard because you
need to have
um a you know a base that can handle it
you need to build the base you need to
build the base and you need to build the
structure and it needs to be weather
resistant and all these things right
and so then we started thinking well
wait a second the world has a 3d
landscape already
right it's called houses it's called
buildings right
so we started saying well what if we
couldn't optimize
the structure itself as we did here but
what if we could take the
the the landscape that we have available
to us and optimize around that
so we've been looking at things like you
know we can take all the rooftops
from google and we can actually
3d print them right so we can 3d print a
neighborhood and then we can think about
how let's say if if a block if a city
block in cambridge
all calls home depot today and says i
want solar panels
every house will get their panels
perfectly aligned for the house
right but the question is what happens
if the houses work together
what are the collective effects could a
neighborhood do better by working
together the answer is absolutely so
we've
we've done the simulations and i have a
a fun little two house
demo here that i don't have time to show
you but you guys should come up and play
with that afterwards
and break it you know touch it feel it
measure currents and you'll see
that by going 3d you can actually open
up possibilities
where you never would have installed
panels before you can now install panels
because you're using
the neighboring house to help you get
sunlight right mirrors are cheap
whether anyone wants to put mirrors on
their house is another question but
anyway okay so i'll i'll stop there and
uh
and i think we take questions now right
what do we do
we sit down we sit down okay thank you
yeah
ooh i was over time you didn't see that
okay okay guys i was thinking like about
innovations and innovations are made by
people they don't just
come out by themselves so and i have two
people right here so
if you would like to share something why
you're in mechanical engineer in boston
you're right
i'm material science recovering
physicist
right yeah so
why are you interested in this kind of
like solar energy projects and
is it more interesting than other scenes
you're doing or how it compares and so
why why you want me to answer that first
i'd be happy to okay are you asking
where the ideas come from are you asking
why what motivates you why do you think
it's more interesting than something
else in
material science there are different
problems in material science right
this is true yeah i i think so what
drives me what keeps me up at night is
the following right
you know so if you look at sort of clean
energy technology and clean water fits
into that i like to say water is the
only energy problem you can actually die
from
right um but anyway because they're
closely coupled
but you know these are problems that
actually
the solution to which will be based on a
choice of material
or choice of design now what's
interesting about that
is that that's very different than
previous revolutions that we've had so
how many of you know
how many how many steps go into making a
chip in your phone
how many elements are even in your phone
does anybody know elements from the
periodic table take a guess
30 good guess how many it's actually
higher 43
43 excellent guess it's actually 62
62 elements are in this phone there are
only about 90 that you have to work with
right
but the thing is that what's interesting
about it if you ask how many steps are
there
process how many steps are there to make
a chip
in the phone any guesses
it's almost a thousand right it's around
a thousand
but of those how many have a choice in
material how many have had a choice in
material for the last 50 years
it's about 10. okay so this revolution
here that we all know and love
this is a processing revolution this is
not a materials revolution
this is not right it's it's also a
design revolution clearly but the future
of energy
will be a materials revolution because
all the bottlenecks in energy
are essentially based on a choice of
material that's how we're going to get
the efficiency up and the cost down
right and and so that combined with
design is what's going to be the next
revolution that's what gets me really
excited as a material scientist
i get excited so as a mechanical
engineer
i'm gonna i i would agree with uh jeff
here because i think the opportunities
are
at this intersection of materials and
engineering
we as you probably saw from the slides
that i showed that indeed we do take
advantage of a lot of the materials
and a lot of these materials we don't
actually create or invent ourselves
right we rely on materials scientists to
help us
kind of come up with them and then we
get excited about them because now we
can realize new properties and i think
that's really the opportunity right
to be able to tune the spectral
properties right to be able to collect
wavelengths in certain particular
wavelengths
and not collect them in others to be
able to now
effectively transport the heat say have
better thermal conductors
or better insulators in certain regions
which are critical in these kinds of
devices
are i think the opportunities and then
being able to then manipulate them
and integrate them into device right so
it's really this interplay
i think that is really exciting about
especially now that we are facing these
energy problems
and now we're in a well-positioned time
in being able to now control them in a
way control the materials create them in
a way
and i think that's where the
opportunities are too
okay staying on the people's subject you
guys don't actually do work right that
was
your students do and you're postdocs so
when new students come
does it feel like more people are now
interested in doing energy kind of
science
or less is it a lot of interest in new
generation okay
the the phrase we don't actually do work
is a little troubling
i didn't mean it uh but anyway we
we uh yeah we're not in the lab as much
but yes the students are the ones in the
trenches and they do yeah they deserve
all the credit
um but so so uh there is an enormous
amount of
energy in energy uh on the part of the
students in fact i think
really you know if you want to look at
what the problem is the problem is there
isn't enough funding there aren't enough
resources
right so um
there there is much more pent-up demand
and excitement on trying to solve these
energy problems
that i see then there are spots
available for students to work on them
right and that's really the issue here
um and this is a long-term problem right
that's that's part of the issue
this is nothing this will not be solved
in 18 months
this will not be solved in three to five
years right so all of a sudden you know
the the sort of you know the investment
part of this starts to feel
uneasy right so vcs get a little uneasy
when you talk about that but if you want
to be honest about it it's long term
you should look at this as a long-term
problem so how do we invest in that
well usually it's the government that
invests in long-term problems
government funding for energy is very
very little right
very little
so indeed i think we do get a lot of
interest in energy because i think
there's also been a lot of media about
it more and more and
specifically solar has gotten a lot of
kind of renewed
interest but a lot of students come in
and they say they want to do energy and
the reality is i think
we have been doing energy for a long
time it's just maybe not
in that same same words maybe
and i think um and i think a lot of the
fundamental principles
um that uh some of the governing physics
that we've been uh talking about for
decades now can still be kind of used
right in the same sense for
energy problems so and uh and so i think
there's still
and while we and and certainly as jeff
already said that you know
right now funding is still low and as a
professor where you're always trying to
get funding to
uh to write grants you always try to
maneuver in a way to
sell your ideas whether it's energy
right now but the idea is that hopefully
we can
create new capabilities new
characterization tools new manipu new
ways to
fabricate materials so that we can
understand maybe new
and develop new um kind of insights into
kind of fundamental
principles that we haven't discovered
before and then really to take it
and address these really bigger energy
challenges there aren't solutions
near term necessarily and so i kind of
see that as
still as an opportunity in in the way we
kind of still think about more
fundamental kind of um
science problems that we can now also
further pursue and eventually maybe
help us in the longer term
right speaking about longer term and i
completely agree that it takes time all
the innovation takes time
but it's also uneven sometimes it moves
fast sometimes for a long time it seems
to be not to move in where you want it
so how do you feel photovoltaics and in
general like solar
energy science at what stage is it now
is it going to leap somewhere
in the near future or is it going to
maybe it will it
will be another type of leap like in
terms of design or deliver it to
places where it's needed so so you know
first of all i think we should go to
questions soon
because but second of all you know just
a very quick answer that
i you know you can't you can't predict
when
uh when breakthroughs will occur what
you can predict is if that
if you don't support an environment that
has the potential to break those
then they won't occur right so so that's
for sure
but you know innovation ideas uh
creativity
that usually happens at intersections
that you cannot predict
right if you tour the the the pixar
building
or used to be the pixar building now
it's like it's the disney building
um in emeryville california you know
they'll tell you the story about how
steve jobs
insisted on one line one bathroom
in on one floor there's a thousand
people in this building one bathroom
he insisted for four months that there
could only be one bathroom why
the best ideas happen while waiting in
line next to somebody you don't know
right so and it was and they tell the
story passionately
and then they say they compromised
because they built this beautiful atrium
for people to
you know intersect but you just don't
know and and so you have to create an
environment that allows for those
intersections to happen
so that you can get those those
breakthroughs right
yeah oh sorry i'm calling on people and
i shouldn't be doing that
welcome to questions just take questions
this is my presentation oh it's going to
be about a thousand degrees even for a
kind of what they call a low band gap pv
cell
celsius so it is very high temperature
right because it's a thermal emission
process so it really has to really get
to high temperatures
and that is the challenge
that are um being absorbed
is that a question for uh it doesn't
matter
i think i mean there's a lot of uh there
are a lot of interesting things you can
do by nanostructuring materials
and um you know nano has a little bit of
a in a way a bad rap
it got it got i think a little over
hyped you know and of course
you know spider-man well anyway you know
incredible hulk we've got all this like
nano in hollywood and stuff
um and and the um
but the fact of the matter is that we
can actually design materials down to
the scale of the atom
right pretty controllably and in some
ways depending
at low cost and that has opened up all
kinds of opportunities actually solar
cells are always
textured at that scale on the surface
you do that on purpose because you
collect more light
so at that scale solar cells always have
that kind of texturing
uh evelyn i don't know if you want to
well certainly i think you're referring
to and people have been studying like
butterfly wings like you said
to these are kind of natural photonic
structures right and so
we're exactly doing that we're trying to
create now artificial photonic
structurals
structures i'm not doing it my
collaborators but you know they're
really designing it
such that in a way that they can
efficiently kind of suppress
particular wavelengths and uh you know
absorb
and emit particular wavelengths you know
things like that so certainly you could
do that with
structure right and certainly that is an
area that has received a lot of interest
it's broken
mission accomplished right that's good
somebody learned something when they did
this and that's all i care about it's
the learning moments you create
right pick yourself up and move forward
for these kinds of things actually yeah
so all of our we have a whole
neighborhood we printed that's
uh from cambridge and uh there are two
houses over there
and um uh and so you now
uh we have actually thought about this
right about 3d printing the cells
directly into the material uh there are
some tricky
things you have to do because but so you
can so these are silicon
uh i'm i'm guessing the ones in little
sun are either cad tell or silicon
i'm not sure and and so
but there are polymer based or organic
based materials that you can you could
3d print more easily
you're not going to 3d print silicon so
so uh that's something we've thought
about uh the problem there is then you
have this um
this issue that those types of solar
cells tend to be lower efficiency and
they tend to degrade
uh over time you have so you have
packaging problems and so forth
um but i think it's a very interesting
idea to directly 3d print
the active layer into the into the
design
uh so so in this case what we've uh
created is kind of a
layered stack of films right and
certainly there are other types of
photonic crystal type structures that
you can make
and our collaborators have been working
on these uh these
two-dimensional photonic crystals which
is i think what you're referring to with
these kind of
poor geometries right
oh the amateur size that you have
okay so um so right now you're talking
about the absorption absorber right okay
sorry i was uh confused
um so uh so right now so we have uh
we our active area is about one
centimeter
right and so what we're trying to do is
uh we're working with nanotubes in the
under on the order of 100
nanometers in diameters each but of
course we're trying to pattern it into
an
area and so when we shrink the area
we can get to much higher concentrations
and also get
higher efficiencies right so to the
areas that we shrunk we've
gone down to about an area ratio
uh about uh seven i believe so
it's about uh you know uh over one
centimeter squared area so
that's the kind of uh area that we're
looking at but we're kind of
not necessarily i guess this if you get
smaller and smaller it's really a matter
of
how much input power you have to get to
get a higher thermal efficiency
because of the fact that you have to
still get to those 1000 degree
temperatures
right to emit at this particular the
wavelengths that you want for the solar
cell
so it's really a matter of how much
concentration you want really in a
practical system because we know
actually one of the big challenges with
solar and a lot of these systems are
concentrated and the optic
optics really dominate the cost so
it's um and to be realistic what we're
looking at is a really small area it's
really
kind of what we can do in the lab and in
these kind of thermal systems as you get
to bigger and bigger areas
you minimize a lot of the losses the
parasitic losses that you would have
because now you have much more active
area compared to
the losses say on the edges or something
like that so
so then hopefully also when we have more
of that then we can also tailor it
better so we don't have to go to as
high concentrations either so then we
can deal with smaller if we design it
with these carbon nanotubes kind of
you know we can think about how we
design the area of that
it's not really a question it's just
breaking a
i love it i love it you know we do a we
that is such a great we do a friend we
started a freshman
uh class uh a new class this fall in our
department
and what we said is there's 12 freshmen
and we said think about what you're
passionate about right so first day you
know one kid's passionate about
tennis another kid's passion about you
know
octopus and how they camouflage and so
forth so the next time
we brought these things in and we broke
them we smashed the handle of a racket
and then we analyze them right
and the i mean you talk about learning
moments
right you talk about opportunities for
intersections you talk about creativity
it happens so much when you break things
you learn the most when you pick
yourself up
right so i mean let's hope let's let's
hope that's true for the celtics
well and that's where the the
engineering tries to connect with the
art and actually and the architecture
and so so the code doesn't know about
aesthetics
um it just tells us what is the most
efficient but what it can also do is it
can tell us
how well we do with anything else so we
we actually
purposely developed a sort of a way for
the architectures to put their
designs directly into our code and see
how far out there and it's very
interesting because some of them you
know
very far off but then you do this sort
of double helix type it's not a double
helix but this double spiral thing it
was only ten percent worse
so you know that's something that that
we would probably tolerate because of
how much
nicer it looks right um and so so that's
an excellent point
and and there's there's wiggle room
there right you don't have to be the
most
efficient or the top you just you want
to find the balance
right
all right so i'm going to get started my
name is kyle barker and i'm a recent
graduate of the master of architecture
program here at mit
so i'll be introducing our final set of
speakers um
we're going to run this one like the
lightning round so we have two people
speaking tonight uh professor sheila
kennedy
and professor professor karen gleason
and we'll be looking at
solar applications so how solar
technology is being developed now
and how we're seeing it to be used in
the future
so i'm going to make very short
introductions of our speakers
both of them have bios at their websites
and for brevity i'm just going to give
you the high points
so professor sheila kennedy
is a professor of the practice at mit
previously she's taught at harvard's
graduate school of design
in the university of michigan sheila has
a firm called kennedy and violates
architecture which she founded in 1990
with her partner frano violic
and within uh kva sheila founded
madx which she'll speak to in her
presentation so i'll leave that to her
and then second we have professor karen
gleason
professor gleason is the alexander and i
michael kasser professor of chemical
engineering at mit
and she has also had teaching
appointments of many other institutions
which i'll skip for brevity she has over
200
published academic papers and a dozen
patents
so i'll hand it over to you sheila
hi everybody holding holding up okay
that's good
okay um so i want to just take a very
brief amount of time
and talk about what we can do now how we
can take some of these ideas about
materials and some of these sort of
really
interesting problems and and work with
them today um
and so my uh contact is there as kyle
said if you're interested i'd i'd love
to
to hear from you so um a problem that
really
is interesting is uh
originated with uh this comment that um
oh okay um
andrew
where's our click here right there we go
good paul farmer i was at a conference
several years
ago and it was a conference similar to
this we were talking about scaling up
and how do you reach out to people and
how do you mass produce things and make
them really cheap
and paul stood up and he said wait
market forces
rarely serve the needs of my clients and
paul is a pioneer in healthcare
and by that he meant that in the
developing world if you're really ill
you don't want to hear i have a super
cheap pill um
you want to hear i have a life-saving
pill and it's important to you and i
want to put the best things for my
health
so paul um really got me thinking about
um
the market and market forces how do we
really rethink the problem of scale
i'm thinking about about new materials
so just three
points really quick the first is to go
soft
um how can we use less material
how can we have a smaller carbon
footprint what kinds of materials can we
use because materials
equal energy as jeff said the materials
the energy that goes into making
materials
into heating them into forming them and
into uh
to shipping them all around the world so
if you think about the world and you
think about the way that
we're doing things it's really like
since world war ii
we um centralize productions um
we make one thing and we make it really
well
and we make a lot of it and then it gets
cheaper and then we spend a lot of
carbon
shipping it all around the world so
we're trying to think about
how we can kind of aggregate scales and
how we can sort of change this paradigm
so what i'm working with in the portable
light project
is a flexible solar material which you
see here
it's a cigs material it's a market-based
material you can buy it today
and we're really trying to take all most
of the hard parts
of a lighting kit and remove them so
that we can just
take this kit and get it into shape
fold it up and then take this very
bright led light which is actually a
little
almost too bright um and create a
lantern like a soft lantern so
that's the premise it's very simple um
and we're thinking about that and
developing that
so it's a kit it's an adaptable kit
and so those are the parts inside the
led the flexible panel
a little battery pack of course not
everything is is soft
um you can see the hard battery
underneath here we can scale this we can
add
panels uh we can charge multiple things
to start creating some economy
and that leads to the kind of second
principle which is that people have a
lot of knowledge
and in so many cultures around the world
people have a very
direct connection to textiles and so we
found that by dematerializing
solar energy and trying to turn it as
much as possible into a problem about
textiles
and reflectivity we can really draw on
local knowledge which is good because it
creates jobs for people and that's good
but even more than that
it creates a sense of stewardship for
energy when people are invested in
making something and this pattern was
actually made by
women in a favela a group called
copahoka
when people make something they feel
like they own it um that's the cool
thing about
about making so in the different places
where portable light has worked we work
with these different skill sets this is
a weaver
in the sierra madre mountains who
actually made
a little kit which looks like this this
that's actually the led over there on
the
on the right um and then sometimes you
don't have a single producer making
something because that's not
the most the best way or the way that
people work because people like to work
together
so we've developed a kind of a model
where a one group
one community here are the women in of
copa roca
in rio de janeiro and then here are
another set of benefactors completely in
the north of brazil
um in the amazon so you have two groups
that benefit
in making things and then last the kind
of
adaptable principle like be as flexible
as possible
when you have a flexible solar material
can the whole
kit be adaptable can you actually use
something like this
as a lantern can you then be able to
take it in a different position
walk with it take it outside i use it in
different areas because
more often than not people need two
things they need an
ambient lighting system and they need a
task lighting system
so we're trying to think about that so
we are
developing um really a kind of a
shape-shifting technology if you will
this is sort of the opposite of a brand
it's kind of like above a brand where
you actually
don't see the technology and you you see
glimpses of the same kinds of things you
might recognize one or two panels
in these kits but different textile
configurations that change the shape
and adapt it to the skill sets in local
cultures
and also the need of local cultures so
we can for example
look at um what this looks like in in
mexico
um in kenya you know you have tailors
you have designers
so they're putting that in bags that's
our flat bag flexible light and power
in nicaragua a little bit different
kind of design a different kind of use
people charge
as they walk up and down the beach and
then at night they protect turtle eggs
and they get paid
by conservation agencies to do that so
that's another source of income
and in brazil um the development that
we're moving to
of actually using natural materials and
using disposable degradable materials
so i'm going to just show you a very
short video that's going to take my last
minute up and it's from the portable
light
project in brazil and it was actually i
think you like this because it was
actually
sort of the opposite of a super produced
video
in that it was uh shot in large part
with um
handheld um cell phone uh video
footage that was actually powered by
portable light and there was a little
bit that was done by our partners
it's in portuguese i hope you won't mind
i think you'll
understand it so this shows the context
of portable light in brazil
where we are nationalizing this
technology and
trying to put it in many different small
river towns in the in the amazon
so i'll play the video now oh there
should be um some
sound yeah there we go so this was their
idea put music to it
so working mostly in the rio outer
points this is a typical village there
the whole all of these towns are
portable light towns
hello
all right that's it thank you i'll stop
it here
well there is benefits going last i've
had such great introductions uh for
uh this technology and uh what my group
uh has done over the past couple years
is actually decided to make solar cells
on paper substrates
and you may wonder why that is we saw
the the great
prop that jeff was passing around and
it had a lot of weight in it because of
the two glass
panels that encapsulate the solar cell
so obviously if paper will be lighter
weight
it will also be a lot cheaper if you
think about design the real reason that
solar is not adopted more
is is just too expensive and so for
solar to be attractive you need to be
able to hit a price point of about
140 dollars per meter square and a meter
squared of glass costs
forty dollars so you've already used up
eighty dollars of your budget
so i need some other substrate i could
think about using plastic
but in many cases plastic for
electronics is actually more expensive
than glass
because you can't use the plastic that's
rough like coke bottles
you need to use special material from
dupont which is ultra thin
when they made a kindle using a plastic
display and ended up costing twelve
hundred dollars
so um we decided to go with uh paper
and this requires us to have processes
that work with the rough substrates
uh that represent paper and also the low
temperatures
so uh what you see here are actually um
a 3d
solar cell this one's in the form of a
paper airplane
and there's a youtube video if you'd
like to look at it that actually shows
us
folding it up and running it we like to
think about paper as maybe being
delicate
but we can actually run paper solar
cells
under underwater and one of the
wonderful things about this technology
it really is an intersection
of disciplines i'm in chemical
engineering so i really think mostly
about
molecules and processes and my
collaborator in
electrical engineering uh vladimir
bulovic is really
an expert in organic devices and
uh and and their properties so we put
this two together
we had a fantastic group of uh students
miles clark barr won the student
lemelson prize for inventors
christopher voice is now a gates fellow
at cambridge
and uh sun gap bim is a professor at
uh in in korea and it goes on and on so
really a lot of people contributed to
this particular effort
so how is it that you can make a solar
cell on paper well you need
low temperature processes and we call
the one that we invented in our lab
vapor printing
and it's analogous to things that people
use to build cell phones and laptops
except we're doing organic materials and
we paid particular attention to the
chemistry so that we could do it at low
temperature
and we get many things at once we put
the paper in the reactor
and we basically sublimate or turn into
gas
vapor reactants or solid reactants and
we put a mask in front
of the paper and we get exactly the
design that we
want and if you look at one of the
masked areas at the top here
you look at the close-up you can see the
uncoated paper has this rough
fibrous structure and when we have the
vapor printing what you see is is that
you still see that structure
so you're basically shrink wrapping each
of those fibers making a very
uh adherent surface so this gives you
durability
in what you're doing so that your device
doesn't delaminate
and what we vapor printed here is
actually a transparent electrode so it's
going to be able to let the light into
the active part of
the device the other great thing about
doing
something on paper is that you can do
what's called roll-to-roll processing so
this is analogous to how
uh newspapers are made and it's a much
more economical way to do
uh to do solar cell manufacture you can
imagine
that you really can't roll through a
process silicon wafers
and that's one of the benefits of going
to flexible substrates
so here's how it works we actually have
a paper mask this was made with a
conventional stencil cutter like you
would use for a hobby shop
and you uh put that mask on top of a
piece of tracing paper it goes upside
down in the
reactor and out comes your piece of
tracing paper
with 250 bricks and these are
electrically conductive uh
bricks and we can do this on a variety
of
papers and also textiles there's a
t-shirt fabric
stretchable rubber so we can also make
stretchable
solar cells and so it's your choice of
design of what
substrate you would like to use and so
you can think about
applications which are not solar fields
and i think you saw many of those kinds
of
applications tonight and so to complete
the device i just showed you one layer
basically you have to do this several
more times
and the second layer is actually the
layer that absorbs the
sun's light and this actually is a blue
car
paint so it's very cheap it cleans it
contains copper
the cathode is silver
and the way you put them together
actually allows you to hook up
solar cells in series to get the voltage
that you want we're doing 250
cells the other two things that are nice
about this particular way of fabricating
cells
are that all the elements that are in
this device are things that are earth
abundant so
you can find carbon everywhere and
sulfur everywhere
we don't have things like indium which
are many conventional solar cells
which are rare earth metals and also
make the cells more expensive
and when you put this all together and
you test it you can actually get
out 50 volts from this 7 centimeter
square piece of
paper and you can use this to drive
drive devices so i want to show you a
couple of movies
this is a smaller piece of that paper
solar cell
and it was encapsulated in plastic
and we'll light it from the from the
bottom this is a
am 1.5 light that's typically what's
used to
simulate the sun and you can see that
you can in fact
drive this led clock and this is being
done in air so one of the knocks against
organic solar cells
is they tend to be non-durable so this
is the cheapest roll-to-roll reactor we
have in our lab
our little laserjet printer and
we put it through the cell through there
to show that it survives the flexing and
thermal cycles
we wanted to print something we're not
very creative we just put mit on there
that's you know what
what happens but after it goes through
that process
it still works and uh so and i i have
demos with me here that have been around
for
a year and a half now and the vapor
process just is much purer
and so some of the degradation
mechanisms are gone
not only can we flex solar cells
we actually can fold them
so here you see this particular cell is
putting out 26 volts this again is in
air and you'll see the hands of miles
clark bar
actually coming in and folding up the
solar cell
and the voltmeter shows the voltage
drops and we expect that because there's
less
cross-section with the light but as you
expand
the solar cell back out you can see that
the voltage again
increases and i think this form factor
naturally leads you to think about
foldable blinds that you could have as
indoor solar cells
perhaps with batteries on the header
directly connected to a lighting system
and that and that way you would get rid
of all the transmission losses that you
have
uh in traditional a traditional lighting
system
in a house and the final movie here
is uh the solar cell this one looks a
little bit different so
in the first movie you saw that we used
plastic lamination like you would have
for driver's license
in the second movie we had no lamination
at all in this one we do another
method from our lab that puts on a
hydrophobic coating
and here you can actually see that the
solar cell can go under
water and it still retains its papery
quality
it has two axis bending so if you have
plastic it'll just roll up into a
cylinder
but paper and textiles actually have two
axis bending
so this particular piece of solar cell
you know you're handling it fairly
roughly in air and putting it under
water
and it continues to put out uh the same
amount of uh
voltage that you uh that you have here
and you can see that this really is much
more lightweight and much more flexible
than the traditional solar cells that
exist and we're really excited about
improving the efficiency
currently this cell would be about one
percent efficient
we hope by the end of this year we'll
have five percent efficiency
and that will really start to be
interesting uh for designing novel
uh applications in solar
and some of those are pictured here what
if you had a wallpaper that
was actually solar cells you had a
jacket you could wear
to charge your mobile device we've
actually created a
solar cell on a postage stamp just as a
demonstration
of size this one was two percent
efficient uh
curtains i i think schildis had some
designs and thoughts about that
if you just want to put them on your
roof it's much more lightweight
and you don't have to do structural uh
changes to your building to be able to
support
the heavy weight of the solar cells or
you can take the power with you with the
tents
so i hope that we're able to do this in
large area with the roll to roll
processing we've been working on this
for about
five years now and i i hope that we'll
really be
at scale that this can be commercial in
another three to five
years so it does take continued uh in
investment
and i'd be happy if you have any ideas
about where these solar cells on paper
could be
used i'd love to hear them thank you
very much
okay well that was really exciting thank
you both for your presentations
since both of you are looking at a soft
version you've called it soft in your
case clearly it's foldable it's all
these other things
what have you found how have you seen
this as a paradigm shift in solar
this idea of softness and flexibility
how is like what are the
um beyond the attributes that you
started to outline how do you see this
as something
that is remarkably different than the
rooftop solar array that we've seen
previously
i mean even for the rooftop array it
just lowers the barrier to
implementation
you think about installing it yourself
you could staple it
um to the uh to the roof you don't need
a professional installer
to do that and i think the mobility of
something that's
lightweight is also clearly valuable
for me i think what's uh really cool
about the new materials
is the earth abundant and the fact that
you could actually recapture
some of those materials at the end of
their life cycle you might be able to
take that t-shirt
and be able to then extract some of the
ito or whatever it is
the different solar layers and and
recapture that so i think that's a
complete revolution in terms of of
infrastructure we think of
infrastructure as hard
we think about technologies having a
single form um
and really since i think the early you
know period
of the wars we've we've been thinking
about that so the idea that it could be
adaptable that it could exist on
different substrates is super exciting
well i think people have been obsessed
with efficiency in solar panels for a
long time
which you know we've been talking about
tonight and so there's always this drive
to get to a more efficient
thin film or in this case paper so i
think
what i've heard you talk about in the
past is this idea of generous excess
where you have a material that has less
of an output
but has more applications so it's less
tied to a specific solar angle or
something yeah i think jeff was also
talking about that
as material costs become less
and you have a low heat way of
printing fairly large areas or
even smaller areas very in a very cost
effective way then i think you really do
you really do change the idea of
efficiency
and so if something is easy to make and
it has a low environmental footprint
um it doesn't have to last 20 to 25
years it could
but it doesn't have to um because we can
dispose of it just in the same way we
drop a leaf on the ground and you know
or
a tree would grow another leaf so it's
really it's a pretty
radical new way of thinking about things
yeah i do think you know the solar
industry currently is very conservative
and all of these uh criteria for lasting
really go with being
out in a solar field so they want
stability that lasts
20 years but if you really want a
solar cell that perhaps integrates
directly with your cell phone
to charge it no one is keeping their
cell phone 20 years
and so there's absolutely no reason that
that should be a barrier to entry for
these new technologies it's true
we're being asked innovators and and
creators are being asked to compare
new solar materials or emergent solar
materials with mainstream electrical
technologies and so 25 years all this
kind of stuff
and if you think about it that wasn't
the way that even mainstream electricity
developed
um edison uh went to um the capitol
uh various different capitals in europe
he went to berlin
and he asked people whether they would
like to be the first european capital to
have his
um ac distribution system and they said
what do you mean we're going to put
poles in the ground and then you're
going to have wires going in between and
that's going to be electricity and he
said yes
and they said forget it so his first
application was actually a dc
generator onboard a ship a very small
scale what we would call a niche
application today but that's really how
mainstream
electricity and our grid that we know
today got started through a series of
these
very inventive and kind of corner
markets
and i think it's very interesting that
these mobile applications
you're seeing them insert in rural areas
because then you don't really have to
compete
against grid power and i think that that
is
essential and also transportation
networks in these areas are very limited
and so being lightweight is really a
critical factor
being foldable you don't want to take
this huge glass panel
and try to get it up some rocky mountain
road somewhere
yes because breakability even though
it's good for grant getting and
and mayors it can cause a can cause
trouble um out in the field
sorry her device works too well yeah
i'll just ask one more question then
i'll open it up um
so you kind of are getting at it with
the edison comment but we've always
thought about technology as something
that's had to be scaled to an incredibly
large degree for it to be cost effective
and distributable and all these things
but it seems like in both cases
what you're doing is interesting and
that it actually doesn't have to scale
in the conventional way we think of
you're talking about engaging local
communities
you're talking about something that can
be we can imagine a future where this
could be something that happens
if not in the home near a home
um so because it's a clean technology
because it's a clean texture so it
doesn't have to be out in the outskirts
of the city sequestered where it can be
polluting and we live in the city where
it's not polluting
right so i was just wondering um
i mean it seems like this is this is
again like a paradigm shift
um and so in your eyes is it necessary
to
bring these ideas to a large scale or is
what it's exciting about them that
they're nimble at these smaller scales
i actually think um one of the exciting
things about
uh our process is that it's scalable and
that you could do it in these large
roll-to-roll reactors
and that you know just these reams of
rolls of paper could come out
and then they're very easily
transportable and usable by people
without professional
uh installation or you know you can just
take it
wherever you want it so i like the scale
and the
mobility together i think that's the
interesting intersection
i agree all right
and i live in boston compared to say
california
will it be better for the people in
boston to be wearing
these jackets
um well of course different materials
have different um what's called solar
apertures
um and i think jeff talked a little bit
about this but
um with glass-based silicon
monocrystalline cells
and they have a relatively narrow
aperture which means that you need to
have light directly fall on them more or
less within a range
organic solar and to some extent
these panels which are inorganic scigs
have a broader aperture so you can talk
about light that accrues over the whole
day
in general um the organic
and something that's flexible like this
allows you to not have to walk at a 45
degree angle for example
which might be painful and awkward in
order to collect energy with something
on your back
so you want to be able to catch incident
light that said
you still need to have your solar panel
in light so you would need to be
committed to spend a fairly long time
outdoors
say um five to six hours in order to
collect power to charge a cell phone or
to run a light
an led light say for six hours or on low
let's say for 24 hours
so you need to be out there with your
jacket
in the sun if i'm
north or south of course the
the the principle of the solar panel is
that it
it needs to see sunlight and it needs to
convert that sunlight into electricity
the
um so it has on it a very thin layer of
a floral polymer which is hydrophobic
so uh the device itself actually never
sees
the water it has this almost the same
principle as that heavy plastic that's
on it but just at a much thinner
level so it still behaves like paper
uh
that is true with this for example you
can put punch holes in this
and it will still operate you all can
also partially shade and it can still
operate so it has a lot of benefits that
way
um and we just try to use it
structurally so it's sort of part of the
structure that
the the textile acts in um
in tension and then we compress this and
so we sort of try to build the structure
with it
yeah i mean i think you saw in the
videos i had different size cells
they were all made the same way we
actually used scissors to cut them into
different shapes for
testing i did have one incident where
i was talking to a large group at mit
and i passed around one of these and
and someone actually tore off the corner
of the cell to keep
to keep for themselves but the rest the
rest will work because they're really
the way they're connected in series but
if you had a lot of this there's
really a lot of things that you can do
in terms of the foldability of the
uh of the cells and if they're really
cheap enough
um and you do destroy them it's easy to
replace i
have a question for you karen on those
um like 20
uh the 50 volts or those other metrics
are those like
open circuit voltage or if you applied a
load um or if you looked at
the sweet spot of powerpoint tracking
what would be the the kind of typical
yield in terms of current
end voltage because that's important for
applications right so
um the voltage there was the the voc for
everything
uh in in series and um
i can't remember the current number off
the off the top of my head
we used it to drive an lcd uh display
which
uh needs a relatively low uh current uh
we actually
don't have enough current to drive an
led right now so
we really need to be but at five percent
you should absolutely
um
yeah i i think i think so i think that
would be a tremendous collaboration and
also because of the
ability to fold you don't need a static
3d shape
so you could actually transform it to
take best advantage of the sun as it
tracks across the sky i also think it's
just sometimes just a neat
challenge since i'm i'm kind of living
in the world of let's do something now
right i'm an architect so we don't
we do do research but we generally get
really excited about making things and
building things and seeing things out in
the world working
so one thing that you can also think
about as a designer is just well how can
you work with
the design of the cell as it is do you
really need to change it or can you find
a way to kind of work with that
um so one of the things about um the
silicon the hard cells is that they tend
to be square
that's because they're made out of a log
of of silicon
and then that's cut and then um actually
there's quite a bit of waste to go from
a circle to a square
then their defect so you have to check
for those and so
those square glass um cells are
sometimes difficult to work with in in
terms of design
intent yeah and i think what's really
interesting about what schill is doing
i think there's clayton christensen has
the innovator's dilemma and says what
can you do with parts
that already exist and i think we don't
know really how people will interact
with the
solar or how much they'll pay for it or
what uses they'll find for it and
i think when they do you know the next
generations of technologies that come in
or even cheaper or
more flexible can just insert into those
modes of operation
well today there are cars that have
flexible solar panels actually the same
material but
larger um you see that integrated into a
curved roof and typically they're going
to
power some subset of
applications in the car for example air
conditioning um you can have a direct
drive solar panel which means you don't
need a battery
but when the sun hits that car it'll
circulate a fan which will help make the
air conditioning
more effective in the car or there can
be a certain
load dc load in the car cars a dc
platform
that will be taken up let's say the
dashboard um by
that particular power source
the other thing i would say is that
again we look you know we in the
in the electricity grid look for total
everything you know black or white like
the whole car
the whole city the whole world and what
we're going to
need to see is that they're going to be
steps they're going to be multiple power
sources
there's going to be a transition an
energy transition it's called
as we start developing some things
off-grid but not everything off-grid
and so we'll have to get used to these
ideas of multiple sources
partial powering objects that we plug in
objects that we take with us
objects that we charge in our lives so
there's going to be
much more of a plurality i think of
energy sources
i i've i thought a lot and i've worked
with jeff on
on a similar project that right now is
not in the public realm but a very
interesting project about taking
sunlight and bringing it into buildings
um but i think 3d is really interesting
um
and i think that the the algorithm that
he has that takes inputs and then
generates a series of kind of responses
to that
throwing out the ones that uh the
ancestors that don't work and continuing
on is
is very interesting so i think we could
be much more creative we're stuck in
what jimmy carter did in 1978 you know
he put
uh he had all the good intentions in the
world but he put a solar panel in the
white house
uh put it like flat on he said that's it
and we've just accepted that that that
should be what solar panels do how they
operate that they're glass that they're
hard but they have to have direct sun et
cetera et cetera
and this materials revolution that we've
we've touched on in this panel um
is i think going to change a lot of that
i think
the investment in solar right now it
would be very difficult to
get a company funded in the solar area
uh green energy has been viewed as being
a
very poor um investment you know there
were bankruptcies like solyndra
has been huge consolidations in the
solar producers really driving each
other
the prices below what can be sustained
and so you have huge companies going
bankrupt and i think it really hurts the
technology and someone really
needs to sustain it i first did solar
energy when i was a graduate student
uh 25 years ago and after my thesis i
didn't do it for
20 years and that's true of a lot of
scientists and all the momentum from 25
years ago
was generally lost most of those people
did not pick up again
and so it would be unfortunate if we
lost this round of momentum as well
so thank you all for joining us for
tonight's program i
i hope you found it as sort of inspiring
and fascinating as i did
we heard from you know a number of
people about their
very varied projects their very
different approaches
to using solar technology to developing
technologies to harness solar power
and i think you know we might all uh
sort of think on our own
uh what new projects we might want to
pursue or support
how solar maybe isn't what we always
sort of thought it was it actually takes
many shapes and forms and has
some pretty wonderful applications for
people not just in our own community but
around the world
thank you very much to our panelists and
moderators thank you very much and
thank you all for joining us this
evening have a good night